I swore to uphold the tenets of the  Creed to never compromise the assassin  Brotherhood to stay my blade and the  flesh of the innocent  I was a damn fool  do you swear to uphold the principles of  our order and all that for which we  stand and to do so from now until death  whatever the costs I do you are now a  Templar  had such hopes for you che  you will die and the traitor who are you  to decide what's a debug Zach  by the wrong shed you betrayed the  Brotherhood Kitty Sammy I will not let  you destroy everything we are film this  bad grab for power it has now  pre-order not receive the siege of fort  de sabah mission and the ultimate hunter  pack pre-order now available November  11th exclusively on Xbox 360 and  PlayStation 3